congratulations to the entire Tulsa King
Family you have told me before that
you've always wanted to play a gangster
Mr Stallone you were born for this role
I'm just a gangster at heart
Gangster of Love No it's just I just
felt that I wanted to try something
where he's a tough guy obviously but he
also has a sense of humor a sense of
heart a little off-kilters
I might be in charge with almost getting
a shot because I don't think that's a
crime even in Oklahoma there's a little
something for everybody that you give in
this series yeah because there's other
actors that have done it so well the
ominous Factor very very dark it can't
be better and I thought well we
I haven't seen this part so this is kind
of comedic because life is funny and
when you see a guy you know fish out of
water situation it's unexpected and
there's nothing better than seeing Sly
as a gangster cracking jokes it's so
good now of course anything that Taylor
Sheridan touches and you touch turns to
Gold how much do you hope that Tulsa
King follows in the footsteps of maybe
Taylor's other work like Yellowstone
that has kind of created this entire
universe well that's the we're very
optimistic if that's going to happen but
what I like about it is Yellowstone is
taking you know really a harsh look at
reality and this one also deals with the
Western world but you know it's
different so he encompasses both aspects
of it so to be very very very
opportunistic yeah I feel like you guys
will be around for a long time there's a
lot of story to tell here especially
when it comes to the family of course in
the series Dwight's family is a bit
estranged and your beautiful family is
here tonight with you you guys are
anything but now how much does it mean
to you to have the support of your
daughters here tonight and of course
your beautiful life that's the whole
care I used to have my priorities all
screwed up you know work came first and
eventually I came out of that delusional
thinking and they come first so you're
right they actually have them here
that's what it's all about and we're
going to see it all in the reality
watch out
[Music]